so where do you see yourself in five
years honestly I'd love to be married
with a baby yeah I mean figure out a way
to work from home and maybe just come
into the office as needed sounds great
okay just want to let you know I got the
email that looks what's wrong Henry just
see all that me and a meeting for
something I didn't even do so feeling
power cried in the bathroom for ten
minutes but now I'm fine sorry toughen
up kid very funny so need to bake
yourself a sense of humor hey wait you
wanting a dinner Friday my treat
like a like a big group thing you hang
out no just a date oh oh I would but
it's so I've got this okay no pressure
we will definitely be together because
he will leave this girlfriend and dabio
me all right but you talked to me about
this guy every day you never listen to
any of my advice I'm sorry I can't hear
it anymore it's not healthy I mean we
can discuss in the movie next week yeah
oh I gotta go change my tampon
well that was really fun yeah I'll see
you later I guess I should walk you to
your car no I don't need you to walk me
to my car I'm fine it's right here so
that's safe okay it's right here but I
Chris I'm okay
Chris it's literally right here Steve I
should I feel like I need to you want to
supervise me getting in I love you